my name is Peter Roberts and I'm the
chief executive officer of the Americas
for Jones La Salle and all the questions
that were posed here in Davos as was
your favorite novels no mistake i must
say that my favorite moment so far was
the social media panel I just came from
right actually this menu youtube reminds
me of rita baited a lot that's happened
with social social media what's going on
with richard i think some of the key
message over the next 18 months it's all
about mobile mobile to mobile some of
the big battles coming up raphy between
google+ and facebook mary and also from
the platforms the content providers and
the pipes or the gatekeepers through
which the content gets stream that's
what the future holds in social media
I'm rule I think it's going to impact
our lives on our business world if you
mention the next phone they commit so
far that's been my favorite all very
good double check run difficulties 30